[Applause]
cool man you ready to go yeah sure
thanks for coming up here were you were
you followed on your way up here not too
much where are you sure I guess I guess
if that was being followed I wouldn't
probably know about it's like you say
that in jest but I was reading an
article I don't know which one it was
but you were doing an interview I like a
New York hotel and I'm sure this was
this wasn't a recent it's probably right
around Sundance I would imagine but
according to the reporter you know it
looked like you were a little bit
concerned that certain people were were
kind of keeping an eye on you it might
have been when I was in London where
they had some extra security around me
but I guess I feel relatively safe yeah
and how has it been I mean is that
something that you think about or you
feel pretty okay with everything I think
I felt about it a lot more when Gregory
had first arrived to Los Angeles in that
period between understanding the
information that he had and and the
evidence that he had and and are going
to to the New York Times with the story
which for me and for Gregory and my team
really felt aside from the need to do
that but that it would also make it a
lot more public and also in many ways
[Music]
make Gregory safe right and by bringing
that information forward so that
seven-month period I felt a lot of
stress but I'm recently and since the
release of the film you know I feel like
that the story's public so I don't know
what would be gained right to to come
after myself ultimately I'm
I'm a filmmaker and and and worked in a
journalistic capacity to bring the story
forward with Gregory but I personally
I'm not the person who who did this we'd
be in the crosshairs of a horse
well let's unpack it I mean the movie is
extraordinary you did an unbelievable
job I was deeply impacted by it and it's
really quite something like it is it is
quite a piece of work like you should be
very proud I'm sure you are and it's an
exciting time for you I mean I would not
be surprised if you got an Academy Award
nomination for this movie in fact I
would expect that to occur
so congratulations it's very cool and
it's a really powerful story so before
we kind of launch into it maybe we can
create a little context for it I mean
it's really birthed out of your your
passion for cycling which has been you
know a huge part of your life for a long
time living here in Malibu you're a
fixture in the Malibu cycling scene and
we have lots of mutual friends and it's
funny right before the pockets you
should you've been in my house before I
wasn't here you were riding with some
usual friends of ours and that's that's
funny that's like you know that's what
it's like to ride a bike around here so
tell me a little bit about your history
with cycling well thanks a lot for the
fill of warm accolades and for me and
the film it's it's just important for me
that people see the movie because I
think the the story in the film is is is
something that people need to see to
understand the geopolitics of what's
going on in our country and in Russia
and you know far beyond the boundaries
of sport what the film is essentially
shines a flashlight into which is you
know what Russia is willing to do to win
and that transcends sport it goes into
you know winning at all costs
and and essentially without without a
moral compass and in what those stakes
are
involved in what you're willing to do to
win so you know so that I am hoping that
any accolades that get presented to the
film wall will be exciting for me the
bigger thing for me is that it will make
people see the film and hopefully open
up a much deeper and broader
conversation in this country and
internationally on the subject matter
that's in the film and really the bottom
line is Russia and Russia's meddling not
just in sports but in geopolitics as far
as my my cycling background yeah I mean
I I kind of started when I was 13 years
old I I grew up racing and in Colorado
and it's just has been in my DNA and I
and I got into cycling really because
five foot eight I'm skinny guy and the
reality was I wasn't gonna be a football
player or baseball player or a
basketball player and when I briefly
tried those sports I quickly found
myself ill-equipped to compete and and
cycling is is really such an individual
sport and a very mental sport as far as
the kind of pain threshold that you that
you put yourself through and and so I
think cycling for me has really been my
my therapy through life it's just been
something that has kind of I've always
went back to and grounded me and and
it's really my passion for cycling that
started me on this journey that became
icarus and that ultimately became this
this film and so you you end up racing
in college right in Boulder or uni and
then at some point you have like a big
kind of career-ending crash yeah I had
raced I started my first races were like
13 14 15 they had in in Colorado these
things called the red zinger mini
classics
and it was literally Jonathan Vaughters
and Bobby julik and and all the Hincapie
eventually because he was over at the
Olympic Training Center and trying to
remember all the guys who were in those
races Chris weary and yeah and so was
all those kind of guys of that
generation and I had I grew up you know
and I was racing for about seven years
really really seriously and when I was
19 I was racing cat 2 and racing jr. was
my like I was technically no longer a
junior but my racing age was still
junior so I was racing both and and I go
and I do this race called the Tour tobot
to be up in northern Quebec and it's
this very prestigious junior race most
of the best guys in the world of did it
when they were when they were juniors
international field and I did pretty
well there and the following weekend I'm
staying in Canada to do this race called
the festival international de hole and
it's pouring rain and I'm gonna break
with about 10 guys and there's about
five K to go and I'm doing the math and
I'm going well the worst place I'm gonna
get his ten and who knows perhaps maybe
I could get top three or something and
and the guy to to bike lanes in front of
me
clips a wheel because it's like pouring
rain people's brakes aren't working so
he starts going over the handlebars and
the guy in front of me hits him and is
going over his handlebars and I'm
watching this in slow motion and I and I
eat his wheel in my mouth literally go
early that we all goes in your mouth
literally going yeah literally in my
mouth and I was probably going you know
30 miles an hour or something like that
at that time and the next thing I know
I'm just in the middle of like a bush
and my immediate masochistic thought is
to get on the bike and finish the race
which I think all the cyclists are
endurance athletes can understand like
somehow even though you're totally
mangled you're
to finish the face and there's that rush
of adrenaline to that clouds
you know logic yeah and and so I just
remember I'm in this bush and and then I
quickly realized that one of my I'm
stuck in one of my pedals hasn't
released and some like going wait did I
break my leg and then I'm thinking that
maybe I like broken arm and then I'm
feeling my mouth and I rub my my tongue
across my teeth and basically realized
that that my teeth are either gone or in
pieces and shattered and and I'm in
French Quebec no less so needless to say
that that crash was traumatic enough
from me that I came back that put me out
for the rest of the season then came
back the next year to try to race and I
just found that my my mindset that that
that difference between taking those
chances to be competitive as anybody
who's into the sport understands we're
no longer there and so I found myself
constantly chasing wheels or opening up
gaps that I shouldn't have opened up or
not willing to take the chances on the
descent that you need to take and and so
I gave racing a break
put down the bike for a few years and
then as I was probably about 23 I picked
it up again and I still ride right yeah
and once that that switch is flicked and
you have that fear like it's kind of
game over to be able to compete at that
level right like if you don't have that
balls-out instinct to just gun it on the
Descent you know rain or no rain then
it's going to be pretty difficult to be
able to be in the mix yeah it really is
and and for for Icarus when I came up
with this idea that I was going to go do
this the whole route in in Europe and
and I'd read about anvil onus they had
this article a couple years ago talking
about like the hardest amateur events on
the planet and one of them was like the
Cape Epic
and another one was I can't even I'm
trying to remember there's another one
in Europe but the one that they rated
the hardest is this whole route and it's
you can do seven days 14 days for 21
days if you're totally off your rocker
but everybody's basically doing seven
days and I read about this race and it's
through the French Alps and it's every
climb that I've ever read about ALP
d'Huez and Mount Vaughn to Angola VA and
Madeleine and it's like the seven
hardest days of like the Tour de France
and I were to put this all together week
into one week and when I get obsessed
with this idea that I'm going to do this
race and part of that is gonna be that
I'm gonna dope but the interesting thing
about that is is that in the back of my
mind there was always that that fear of
what am i doing because to me taking the
drugs or performance-enhancing drugs
whatever the hormones I wasn't scared
about I was scared about flying off my
bike going 70 miles an hour and that was
I think the the biggest variable and in
coming back to kind of just do these two
races and where I don't have contacts
yeah where I was like I'm really just
what am i doing I'm too old to have an
injury like this yeah no I get it what
you do I mean the first time you do
Haute Route is was that 2009 wait no
that was um 2014 2014 and then you got
like 40 but it yeah right so you did
well yeah I mean how many guys are in
our in it there's 440 guys that yeah
yeah so you're like you know you're
right in there and then you have this
idea I want to talk about the genesis of
the idea you're gonna go back the
following year but you're gonna be
you're gonna compete after undergoing
like a full protocol of
performance-enhancing drugs and you're
going to document all of this in a film
so what was the catalyst for that idea
well that that that catalyst and and
which
a whole reason in the beginning as I as
I set off to make Icarus and and
actually named the film Icarus before I
ever even picked up a camera and the
reason why is because I was looking at
Lance Armstrong's journey and I likened
him to Icarus essentially this guy who
just kept flying too close to the Sun
and too close to the Sun and too close
to the Sun and he finally just
essentially got his wings burnt and and
plummeted to the earth and and the
concept for me was I was looking at that
story and going in the popular media if
you talk to anybody they all believe
that Armstrong had been caught but he
actually hadn't been caught it was like
getting al capone on tax evasion and
behind the he's been caught was actually
a program in anti-doping that really
hadn't worked and so I'm going wait it's
it's the beginning of 2013 and here he
is confessing on Oprah but as he's
confessing he still to this day has
passed 500 tests right he never failed a
test never never failed a test now
scientists can go back now and they can
go well you see this anomaly in his
blood past board and here he would be
suspicious for you know for with rope
Oita noose or whatever they want to look
at but the bottom line is that he had
not failed a test so I'm going forget
about Armstrong what does this mean for
for the world of sport that if the most
tested athlete on planet Earth isn't
being caught by the science that's in
place to catch him and ultimately as a
society where we're mad at Armstrong but
in flipping you know that on its head
should we be mad at the system that
clearly is ineffective and leaves the
athlete with the choice to make rather
than being so upset at the individual
athlete from make
that choice when ultimately the athlete
wants to win mm-hmm and what is involved
in winning so so I was exploring that
and and I saw as I started long before I
picked up a camera I started talking to
all these scientists and one after the
other would tell me that essentially you
can get around the testing essentially
you can still get around the testing
regardless of of Armstrong confession
and that it was essentially this
constant cat-and-mouse game and many of
these guys that I was encountering and
speaking to said to me yeah we could
help get you around it but we don't want
to be involved in it but it was based on
on this kind of hypothesis that I had
that set me out on this journey because
I thought it would be really interesting
because we you know I had never seen on
camera and I think it would came from
both a personal curiosity but also in
looking at a in a in a journalistic
fashion of how to kind of tell this
bigger story that everybody's curious
about what these drugs do or don't do
anybody who's an athlete or an armchair
quarterback they all you it's always a
topic of conversation and I was very
curious a to see what the drugs did and
be to explore whether or not this system
worked and if it didn't work and
assuming that it didn't work essentially
presenting to society or anybody who's
gonna watch this film the larger
question of the hey what do we want to
do about this what can be done about
this should we care should we not care
and that was kind of II then the the the
blueprint that I had set out and
initially going to make Icarus right so
the inquiry from the outset is is
bifurcated on the one hand it's like
what's it like to do all these drugs and
what's going to happen if I do it and go
compete like how will I feel how is that
going to impact my performance like
let's document it and show the world
what this is really all about and the
second prong being all right we know
that the system's broken Lance Armstrong
got through we know many other athletes
have but how broken is it and how easy
would it be or difficult would it be for
somebody like you to undergo the
protocol that that some of these other
people have done and try to game it and
get by right so the idea was that you
wanted to have your blood test it and
see if you too could be somebody who
could pass these tests correct right
so then it becomes like is it so broken
that this is easy or is it do you have
to be somebody like Armstrong who has a
tremendous amount of resources at his
fingertips in order to do it well I
think what I when I quickly started to
discover was that there are so many
variables so it's not it's not one
versus the other which is ultimately
what leads me to Gregory were chenkov
who's running the at the time is running
the Russian Moscow anti-doping
laboratory which is really the anti
anti-doping laboratory it disguised as
the anti-doping laboratory and and and
what I found was that you know any kind
of [ __ ] in the armor one thing out of
place could essentially disrupt the
whole system so that you know if you
look at it from like the Armstrong
perspective of it well that game was
always about how do you essentially keep
one step ahead of the science and going
okay we know that the tests that they're
using for HGH essentially can only
detect HGH within about a 12 hour period
so we know if we if I take HGH at this
time in the day and I can you know and
even if they show up for a test I can
you know I'm gonna be I'm gonna be okay
as long as I have this timeframe we know
that if I take this much of
erythropoietin but I set these different
values and take this this amount that
I'm not going to test positive and so
you know the the Armstrong of it was
always trying to stay one step ahead of
the science and in his case you know he
had a lot of advisers as did you know
his team as did other writers of that
generation I mean the I think the
amazing thing that when they catch him
we learned that life heimer and Hincapie
and all of his other teammates had been
doing the exact same thing as that he
had been doing his entire career and
these guys had never been caught so that
is the the one side of it and then
there's then then there's the the chinks
in the armor and that's the broad chain
cops of it the the Gregory were Chang
cops of it meaning if you've got
somebody within the lab who's altering
your samples or who's working for the
Russian ministry or how it is one step
you need to worry about your science or
controlling the sign because you're
you're controlling exact yeah and you
kind of launch into this you know on
this mission to explore these two prongs
and and it's it's there's a certain
levity to it like I wouldn't go so far
like it's sort of been compared to
Morgan Spurlock and supersize me like
it's not a it's not like a comedy in
that regard like I feel like you
approached it with a little more
seriousness than maybe you know someone
like Morgan would have but that was
really the exploration and the focus and
then you meet Gregory rich ankov and
we're gonna get into who he is and the
impact that he had on on this story
and the whole documentary shifts focus
away from that narrative and into what
really becomes like a john lecarre a
novel like this crazy spy novel you know
Bourne Supremacy type situation with
gigantic geopolitical implications and
this firestorm this maelstrom of a
scandal that suddenly you find yourself
in the center of I mean as a documentary
filmmaker in certain respects like
looking at it completely objectively
like that's a gift and it's also that's
what makes documentaries great when you
go on this journey and you're open to
whatever is gonna happen and these magic
things sort of occur and then you can
follow that story and it become
something else altogether
yeah I mean it's certainly you know the
the film once we got into the the
creative filmmaking process of it after
you know shooting hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of hours of footage and and
aside from what the story was it became
on a filmmaking level with my team of
how to shape and craft the narrative
into a thriller and to make you feel
that you were simply in a you know a
narrative thriller that happens to all
be true and so it is a documentary and
and that came from what I was truly
experiencing during that time on a daily
basis an emotional level and so as we
went back to kind of shape the film as
looking at Paul Greengrass movies and
write doug liman films yeah handheld and
and and you know an arrow Morris on the
documentary side and Laura Poitras for
citizen four and a man on wire and and
so thinking about how to kind of like
blend these worlds of of this true story
which is a documentary and the thriller
aspect of of what was really going on in
my life and ending Gregory's life and
the stakes that were involved but to but
to craft kind of the narrative to bring
you into that story and keep you engaged
and that was that was a very long
process of my team from you know the
music and the sound and the editing and
how we and how we put that together to
have that hopefully that emotional
effect and it changed from Sundance to
the release on Netflix right quite a bit
after that quite a bit we had a the film
was acquired at Sundance and and Netflix
came to the table and for me the Netflix
of it
was the best option for people to see
the film because we're in a kind of a an
error where it doesn't matter what your
documentary might be people are
conditioned now that they're gonna see
documentary essentially on Netflix or
they're gonna go see it on HBO etc where
the days of literally going to a movie
theater when your option is is do I go
see whatever it is the new Star Wars and
that's going to be my hundred dollar
evening at the movie theaters or am I
going to go see a documentary the
majority of the population is gonna go
choose to see Star Wars and so with that
in mind you know the Netflix of it to go
into a hundred and ninety countries at
the push of a button and have your film
translated into every language that
Netflix is their platform was operating
in to me was was a no-brainer because
ultimately I wanted to see to it that
that the film was seen so they acquired
at Sundance and creatively we had raced
to get ready to Sundance when they when
they let you know that your movie is
into Sunday and she basically have like
seven days and you don't sleep yeah and
you know and so we had you know we had
enough we hadn't slept for the months
and months leading up to Sundance to
submit you know cut to them how they an
hours of footage of you shoot total it
was hundreds hundreds and but then
bringing in the you know the thousands
of archival clips and how to basically
craft you know the narrative around the
footage that we shot but then the
archive whole Plus bringing in CGI and
motion graphics and and recreating that
lab etc but sunette flicks acquires and
and sit down with them and just say hey
look we think this film can be better
these are the things that I want to keep
working on
and a Netflix said okay sounds good to
us and so we kept working for for four
months after Sundance it was like
Sundance it was like the editing had
never stopped we just went you know we
were sleepless up until Sunday and
Sundance happens that's two weeks
Sundance ends and the very next week
we're just back at it like it never
happened
but that four months they allowed two
things one allowed for me and my team to
have an audience already have seen the
film and as you see it over and over
again you become more and more critical
as a filmmaker of going way that that
can be better that can be better we can
do this we can do that and to and you're
able to then go back and and work
already knowing what is really working
and where you feel like the movie can be
better refined and so is that was an
amazing opportunity that a lot of
filmmakers don't have to come out of
Sundance and then continue to be able to
work on their film and a Netflix was
incredibly supportive been an amazing
company to to work the best portal for
you to be on by our I mean the number of
eyeballs that you can reach there versus
any other platform it's not even you
know comparable yeah they're amazing so
alright so so you're you're launching
into this adventure and and you have
this idea but you're gonna have to find
the guy who's gonna walk you through how
you're gonna do this
performance-enhancing protocol right
like who you know who do you call and
what leads you to this guy Gregory well
you know we don't get into a lot of the
detail in the film we we dangled the
carrot without getting into the real
backsword because you know you only have
so much time and and yeah in a feature
but essentially as I started out before
I even picked up a camera in this thing
and I'm talking to scientists I get put
into touch with Don Catlin and I went
after actually Don Catlin I actually
sought him out because I knew that he
was a essentially the the foremost
science
in US history and in the development of
the anti-doping system all right here in
the first lab for the first lab the UCLA
lab and he did the first-ever testing
for the 84 Olympics in Los Angeles he
went on to do the testing for the
Atlantic of the Atlanta Olympics he went
on to do the testing for the Salt Lake
City Olympics so this guy is widely
considered one of the most knowledgeable
and foremost scientists in the world on
anti-doping and and also laboratory
operations so in the early days of
coming up with kind of the the thesis
for the film I reached out to Don Catlin
and we started having lunches and he's
in Los Angeles and and talking by phone
and and I you know told him essentially
what what I wanted to do which was hey
Don do you believe that the anti-doping
system in sports works and he said no I
said do you think you know what are the
probabilities of it ever really working
and and he basically said well I think
it's very difficult and he went on and
listed a million different reasons and
and at the time Richard pound the head
of water had actually just released a
report and this report which dick pound
authored also got into huge detail as to
all the different fallacies of the
anti-doping system um what it was facing
in its reality to succeed on on a global
level and Saddam did you also sorry to
interject but didn't you also ask Don
like how many athletes do you think at
this yeah I start doping yes
and so I'd asked on you know how many
what percentage of the athletes do you
think are doping and and and he said all
of them and I said well why do you
believe that Don he goes well prove it
to me otherwise and I said well how can
I prove it to you Don because well
you can't sew so we he was looking at it
from a perspective of not that everybody
is taking performance-enhancing drugs
not that everybody is cheating but
anyone who's adequately motivated to
circumvent that check balance can do so
exactly but but but he was looking at in
the in in his personal experience and
going hey I I thought I tested on from
50 times I never got him I ran the lab
and I saw you know so he was looking at
it on a personal perspective going hey
every time I thought somebody was
cleaned then something would come come
down the line that they weren't clean
and so I can't prove to you that they
are clean unless essentially you're
gonna put an athlete into like a biodome
system have him under 24/7 surveillance
where there where you know you're you're
monitoring them every eight to 12 hours
so so Don was very candid in his beliefs
and is he still professionally involved
in well no he was retired he was retired
and I think his willingness to speak to
me also had to do with the fact that he
was retired meaning while he was still
in the system on a day-to-day basis it's
very hard to kind of speak about the
problems within the system well at the
same time that's your livelihood and
that's your job which i think is also
part of the yin and yang and the and the
two-sided nature of this issue but
problem is that a lot of people involved
in it that even understand it are not
going to go and speak against it because
it's there because it's their livelihood
so
should we wait this is current week away
it's alright yes this is life so so I
sedan originally says to me that he'll
help me essentially design a protocol
and and advise me on how to essentially
get around the system and in so doing
and why he was willing to help you just
like sir yes I think in the beginning
and that changed I think he was I think
he was interested to show firsthand the
fallacies in the system that he himself
couldn't expose but as a retired
scientist as somebody who had kind of
spent his life his life's work trying to
do something about it I think he was
interested in exposing all saying you
could shine a spotlight on this then
it's the narrative shifts from oh
there's a few outliers like Armstrong
who can get around this to know there's
a wide gaping hole here that anybody can
walk through exactly and I and I and and
when I was approaching the film I was
approaching it that Armstrong was the
haystack
and not I'm sorry the that Armstrong was
you know not the the the needle in the
haystack that he was the haystack he
just he just happened to be the best of
his generation but ultimately doing the
same thing that that most of the
athletes of his generation were doing as
well so so I was interested in in in
exploring that story but on a global
sport level and and and Catlin thought
that was an interesting idea but along
that came all these variables which is
first of all how are you gonna get your
samples into a wada accredited lab and
that's easier said that done because
technically it doesn't matter if you're
professional athlete or an amateur
athlete you can't just get your samples
into a waddle
because if you can get a waddle lab to
test your samples
well then anybody can essentially figure
out how they can gain the system if
they're sending in their samples every
day and going okay am i positive now am
i positive now do I test positive now
happening yeah and so so there was a
huge variable there of how you're going
to get your samples into a Lam and as
dong got further into and out of the lab
sorry ruff you all labs are registered
with wada so yes you just can't do it
that's right a lab and you can go to
that's right well I guess there was a
lab you to go to so so dawn says look I
I ultimately can't help you I I don't
want to be advising you I can't
prescribe you what you need and I don't
want the liability of that if something
were to go wrong or you were to be get
you know injured or hurt or have a heart
attack whatever that is and third of all
I can't get your samples into a water
lab but there's a there's a scientists
who I know that I think might find this
interesting
yeah I got the guy and he connects me to
to dr. Gregory where chenkov and Gregory
at the time is running Russia's
anti-doping laboratory and this is now
right about the time of Sochi and we
don't get into this into the film so
this is March of 2014 basically he was
just finishing or you know it was like
he was actually at Sochi as we first
started corresponding and I approached
him and I just said hey I'm a
documentary filmmaker I'm interested in
discussing with you the fallacies in the
anti-doping system Don Catlin referred
me to you would you be willing to kind
of like talk to me and I didn't tell him
what I wanted to do at the time it
wasn't like hey this is what I'm gonna
do
will you help me to open evade detection
but we go back and forth on an email
exchange and he invites me after a
couple months of course bonding
and we'd actually spoke on the phone a
few times he invites me to go meet him
in Oregon and this is July of 2014 he's
lecturing at this symposium in Oregon
and I make this decision that I'm not
gonna go up there with a film crew I'm
not gonna spook them I just want to go
up there and meet him because I don't
know at the time is this the right guy
is he gonna help me what you know what
am I really getting into other than this
is a Russian scientist who just did all
the testing for Sochi he's clearly a man
of interest and could clearly advise if
he wanted to so I go up there and meet
him we spend a couple days together and
we we end up drinking even though I'm
training but you know it's just what you
do when you're around a Russian
scientist and and I asked Gregory I say
do you believe that an Olympic medal a
medal in the Olympics can be won without
performance-enhancing drugs and he looks
at me and he goes I should believe I
tried to believe that I do not believe
that an Olympic medal can be won without
performance-enhancing drugs across the
board yeah any sport and then he pauses
and he goes I don't know maybe I'm a bad
man and what do you make of that and I
and literally it was okay what do I make
of this and and and he agrees to help me
on this journey after this conversation
I tell him what I want to do and he says
I like challenges this sounds
interesting you know and um you were
making a sound yeah and which you know
of course was kind of surprising in the
Wow
this guy should not be doing this this
is against his his job this is against
wada code the world anti-doping agency
code and not doing this yeah I'm like
Alan he's gainfully employed he's
exactly exactly and unlike Catlin you're
still in the system this is still your
job but he agrees to help me because we
kind of form
this this trust this relationship and I
say and at the time I even said hey look
you know anything we film when the
movies done I'll show it to you and we
just kind of just hit it off and and so
he agrees to help me and about six
months later this is July 2014 I then
starts speaking to him and this is where
the film picks up and this is the first
time we see him in the film on skype and
it's a first Skype conversation I've
ever had with him as well and there he
is and I'm ready to start doping and
literally as I'm getting ready to start
doping this German television special
called like a 60 minutes comes out and
this German reporter who had been
investigating Gregory in the lab comes
out with this scathing TV program
alleging that Russia has a
state-sponsored doping program and that
Gregory were chenkov this is essentially
one of the very very key key figures in
this program and so this news piece
comes out right is on literally starting
my doping program and and so Gregory is
under investigation the entire year that
he's advising me how to dope
so he's under investigation while at the
same time he's coming to Los Angeles and
helping me smuggle my urine back to
Moscow I'm in myriads of Skype calls
with him where he's advising me on my
protocol and and what happens is over
this year we truly truly form a
friendship and as this investigation is
going on I'm quietly behind the scenes
which I don't get into in the detail of
the film but but I'm going and
interviewing all these guys that are
investigating Gregory and asking them
none of them realized that I know
Gregory none of them realized that I'm
doping but I'm just asking them as
you mentary filmmaker so with these
allegations against Russia proved to be
true what does this mean do you think
you know that this happened what do you
think is Gregory's involvement in this
what you know so I'm coming out
gathering all as a documentary but but
what I'm doing is I'm and my team is
that we are essentially planting kind of
all the seeds should the other part of
this story turn into something a lot
larger Isis and you're already aware
that this pivot might be a play myself
and my producing partner Dan Cogan with
impact partners and my my editorial team
and everything we were we were very we
didn't know how big it was going to be
but clearly as I come out of Oregon and
I'm doping and this investigation is
going on I mean I was I was very mindful
of the fact that there was an
investigation going on but from a
narrative focus in the film I couldn't
rely on that I had set out with a
hypothesis that the anti-doping system
has lots of problems I'm gonna show
first hand you know what it is to dope
how to evade detection how much better I
get and and I have this Russian
scientist doing this and he shouldn't be
doing that to begin with and that to me
would make a decent or a compelling
documentary in and of itself I mean that
that worked for Morgan Spurlock and
supersize me and in in and of itself I
thought that that was going to be
compelling but I also knew that there
was another story unfolding and there
was an investigation going and that
Gregory was was being focused on and so
when he watched that film every time we
see those skypes I'm always then talking
about the investigation what do you
think will happen and then you know we
we cut to somebody may be commenting on
it so we were we were very Oh
that there could be a much bigger story
there but I wasn't going to put all my
eggs into that basket so I said during
that time I was essentially continuing
to make the movie that I was setting out
to make that that my producing team and
my investors had had come in based on
that hypothesis while at the same time
I'm I'm investigating and and and making
sure that I'm prepared should ya shoulds
developed this other thing developed
with Gregory that turns out to be ads it
turned out to be a you know a hundred
times bigger than that I think any of us
could have imagined at the time the fact
that he was under investigation and this
60-minutes type show airs right it
essentially the outset of your
involvement with him in terms of him
helping you figure out how to do-- makes
it all the more amazing that he would
agree to do this and i know you know
you've thought a lot about this and it's
not sort of as expressly addressed in
the movie but looking back like why do
you think that he jumped on board to do
this with you because in the mood i mean
the guys like a gift because for a
filmmaker i mean he's so he's got
charisma
he's funny he's gleeful like there's an
enthusiasm and you know the the bond
between you guys is really palpable and
I think that really anchors the
emotional you know core of the story
which you know it's great for you as a
filmmaker but it still begs the question
like what is he doing this
well I he had a bigger story to tell and
and I think his as our trust developed
he knew that unlike like this German
reporter that had essentially broke the
first piece of the story that we had a
friendship and that I was not going to
stab him in the back I wasn't out there
to to exploit a story
and he had went through a lot of kind of
moral conundrums you know first of all I
think we have to look at how the sports
system in Russia works which is unlike
the US or most Western European
countries where sport is kind of
privatized or let's say you're playing
on the basketball team well here you're
playing for the Los Angeles Lakers and
you're being paid a salary for the
Lakers in Russia you're playing for the
ministry you're playing for the Russian
government and the Russian government is
writing your check and essentially every
single professional athlete in Russia
like it was during communism and as it
is today are essentially government
employees you're essentially an athlete
for the Russian government and Gregory
was an employee of the government and he
came up in that system that that is
essentially the Russian government is in
charge of sports and the Ministry the
sports ministry is a part of the Russian
government so you know he had grown up
in this system but this is how it was
done and I think that that as the years
went by and the ass got bigger and
bigger he saw himself as as a disposable
cog in that wheel and his career which
we don't get into and in the film in
detail as there were many times where he
was forced to sacrifice an athlete
essentially you know where the athlete
would be reported positive because you
know if nobody tested positive well that
looks like Russia's up to some right it
doesn't yeah it's not compare so they're
gonna have to throw somebody under the
bus right so so he's huge part of that
right program so he's dealing with this
this ethical conundrum that he's
constantly having to throw athletes
under the bus that that you know that
that believe that he's protecting them
that trusted him yeah and that are under
the belief that that
they're gonna undergo these protocols
and they're gonna be taken care of
that's right and and there's so there's
that going along the development of the
bottle swapping system I think he came
out of Sochi and his willingness to
start working with me was that he had he
had believed that this system had
reached its logical conclusion and maybe
explain the system a little bit about
what happened in Sochi so people would
what prior to Sochi the Sochi Olympics
the game for him and the recipe
anti-doping world I guess you could call
it was always the cat-and-mouse game of
a science
so a Gregory's case he's a scientist and
a brilliant scientist and he's
developing tests to catch
Dover's cheaters in sport well at the
same time he's developing the anti-venom
to his own tests so that the Russian
athletes are getting away while other
athletes around the world are being
caught through the methodology that he
created and that's you know full you
know which we get into the film of or
well and doublethink of essentially you
know being both sides of the same coin
right but that the the anti-doping
establishment in Russia is a doping
establishment exactly and it's and it's
and the envy and it's only a front for a
doping operation to pretend to be an
anti-doping operation now that to him
was the world that he knew and what was
always that world but what began to
happen it was no longer about the
science it was just purely about fraud
and what Russia had figured out how to
do was how to break into the urine
collection bottles that are the
benchmark hallmark whatever you want to
call it of the anti-doping system
meaning me the athletes give a urine
sample they divide their sample between
these two collection bottles and a
bottle B ball it's this glass bottle and
they have this top on it and this top is
like Fort Knox you cannot get into it
you can only break the top for the
testing and the B sample stays in
storage for the next 10 years should
they ever need to go back and retest it
so Russia with the help of the KGB the
FSB figures out how to break into these
collection bottles and in so doing they
are able to defraud the entire
anti-doping system because now they
don't need to worry about gaming science
they don't need to worry about
hey did this runner you know stop taking
X drugs seven days before competition
and what amount that they were going to
take and how to mask the steroids within
the within you know that athlete now it
was hey you can take anything you want
and we're gonna just swap out your dirty
urine and put in clean urine in its
place so then the links that they went
to to the machinations behind how they
actually executed on that plan at Sochi
as demonstrated by this incredible
motion graphic that you guys created is
unbelievable truly is out of a spinal
and it is it's like a it's like an ocean
xi ocean 11 heist and they had figured
out even in the construction of building
this laboratory in Sochi how they were
going to game the system and so this was
no longer about science or the doping of
the anti-doping this now his career was
essentially as he said he was their
doggy bag he was the guy that was out
there to to pick up the poop and you
know and and and clean up the mess but
it wasn't about him really being
scientists anymore and he viewed that
this system had reached its logical
conclusion that you couldn't continue in
such a brazen manner and that and that
it had just gotten out of control and
and the bigger thing about that is is
out of the Sochi Olympics as Russia wins
33 medals the highest medal count
and they win 13 gold the most gold of
any country national pride soars Putin's
approval rating soars and he two weeks
later goes into Ukraine and by those
approval ratings lion and and brazen you
know and yes in his right to do so right
and goes in to try to you know take back
a part of Ukraine and and and Gregory
felt in personally responsible for this
he felt that that his success in Sochi
to which he had been awarded the the
medal of friendship by Vladimir Putin
that's the highest honor that you can
get and he literally gotten a medal of
friendship from Vladimir Putin
congratulating him on his success at
Sochi meaning if there's ever any doubt
despite the Russian denials to this day
that they knew nothing about this here
Gregory is awarded right then that look
friend here says that he doesn't even
know who the guy is doesn't know his
name
of course that's that's not true of
course I mean I think it's there's a
couple sort of observations on that I
mean the first is you know it's I think
it's important for people to understand
that like Gregory you know he'd been
violating what we would perceive as a
moral ethical you know code all along
but his his sort of dividing line or his
line in the sand was just a little bit
further down right like he was okay like
he grew up as a elite track and field
athlete his mother was in check if it
was steroids right he was fifteen like
this is his reality right that's right
reality of sport and Russia
there was no dilemma for him until it
reached that point where the fraud
became so pervasive and he actually
wasn't performing work as a scientist
anymore and more as like an errand boy
if like you know like three-card Monte
you know almost so just hide these
samples and stay one step ahead of of
wada and the IOC but that's right and
you know
I think the the amazing thing is
regardless of the of a conversation that
that might want to be hadn't on Gregory
in the sense of well he perpetrated this
fraud he's complicit etc he had to look
at the the extraordinary risks that he
ultimately took to bring this story
public you know had he stayed in Russia
there is no doubt that he would not be
alive today as witnessed by the two
other guys that that perished with this
information one of which was in
conversations with David Walsh that's
correct on the eve of of having a quote
unquote heart attack right that's right
mmm that was Nikita Kamiya who was
running rusada the Russian anti-doping
agency and he was involved in the
conspiracy and when this report comes
out that Gregory flees Moscow and and
essentially escapes to Los Angeles
Nikita
decides that he's going to tell his side
of the story and what happened to David
Walsh because all these guys have been
forced to resign they've been pushed
under the bus they're already being
labeled as the bad guys by the Ministry
even though they were essentially the
employees and and following orders so
Nikita decides that he's going to do
that and makes a plan to meet up with
David Walsh and for people that are
listening he's the journalist to
basically you know chase Lance around
forever yes he's the guy who wrote what
was it la he wrote multiple books on
basically trying to expose Armstrong and
he's a journalist the Sunday Times
journalists who the Stephen Frears
filmed the program was is ultimately
about basically his hunt for Armstrong
and how he essentially gets Armstrong
and anyway so Nikita had been speaking
to David Walsh and before they were able
to meet
he dies at age 52 of a heart attack and
in Gregory's mind this was not a heart
attack at all that this was a a
purposeful death this was essentially a
murder so yeah I mean the stakes were
very high but but Gregory's decision
ultimately to come out and be a
whistleblower and the extent that he
want to do that I think are pretty
extraordinary because he could have come
to Los Angeles and kept his mouth shut
or he could have just said a little bit
or he had multiple options but the ring
is here Don you or he could have
disappeared right now he could have came
here you know got here you know and and
vanished but the fact is is that he
wanted to tell his story and he wanted
to blow the whistle he wanted to bring
this evidence forward and I became the
guy that he entrusted to help do that
and myself and the team essentially
brought on you know Russian translators
people that could help us archive all
the evidence people that could help us
create spreadsheets and documents
because everything was in Russian and
get this to a place that we could bring
this story forward and at the time that
the the story breaks and we bring it to
the New York Times which is in May of
2015 I couldn't have imagined the
current political climate I couldn't
imagine that you know the current US
administration that there would be
charges of Russian meddling and
interference in our election all these
kind of political events that have
transpired in the last year that as I
was deep into editorial on the film and
with this story that shows
what Russia's willing to do on it on a
global level and how intertwined all of
these things are I mean when you see
when you understand that the context
around Putin going into into the Ukraine
the idea that Olympic medals are just
sport gets thrown out the window and you
understand the geopolitical implications
of what it means to as a country to be
successful with the Olympics and how
that can embolden and empower a leader
of that makind of that stature as Putin
and where does it go from there you know
and and I want to get into you you know
the election meddling and all that we're
jumping all over the timeline now I want
to get into I I think we should should
we go back and just talk about what the
doping protocol was like and what
happened through that sure yeah in in
regards to Russia or just in I want to
sort of track your experience on this
doping protocol and then like what
happened to you personally and then it
and then get back into like Gregory and
the larger story well I I had been on a
protocol for about nine months leading
up to this Haute Route and Gregory was
advising me what to take and and when to
take it and how much he came to Los
Angeles he smuggles back all my frozen
urine basically so he can test in his
laboratory my washout period essentially
you know at what point will I'd be clean
how much can I take
what exactly can I take can I not take
to avoid detection and and I go when I
do this second race the film I don't get
into the specifics because I I
technically don't do as well but there
were a lot of variables I had had a
crash I had a flat tire my electronic
shifting broke on a day and I lost an
hour but I truly had was recovering
which was pretty amazing in regards to
all these hormones that I was Tay
that on a performance-enhancing level
this stuff works
I mean I was I was recovering I wasn't
faster I wasn't you know a different
athlete but I was able to go out and put
in a an extraordinary effort and beat
myself you know to a pulp but the next
day I was recovering a lot better than I
had
without the peds and so I was basically
EPO HGH and testosterone yeah
EPO HGH testosterone HCG to supplement
the testosterone I'm going to go off of
that thyroid to increase my metabolism
DHEA all sorts of different vitamin
injections folic acid b12 combination of
different different vitamins that I were
doing trying to think what else I took
yeah that was and that went on for how
long for about nine months I'm on nine
months so and you know weed off and on
and then we taper and figure out kind of
how to do that and I was getting my
blood tested to build a biological
passport for myself and so it was kind
of trying to do everything that I could
to create kind of what this would be
like had I been being tested by by wada
and Gregory is is basically saying I'm
going to figure out the testing we're
gonna get these vials of blood back to
my lab in Russia and that's what we're
gonna do the testing yes yes I we're
gonna get my my urine back to Russia and
then and then I'm gonna bring him all my
urine from the second race the Haute
Route two which I did bring to him in in
Russia after the second race and he was
then going to test to see if in fact I
was clean or not if I was positive or
not
and in everything that he was building
before he basically is forced to resign
from the lab and this whole
investigation breaks it was looking like
I was would have feasibly evaded
positive detection and your experience
of being on you know being on the
protocol was that like was it what you
expected or was it different than what
you expected like clearly it works but
it didn't make you feel like Superman
when you were out training and it didn't
work it wasn't like a magic bullet in
this race you had all these other
challenges I think setting aside the
mechanicals and all of that though they
were like you're I think you said your
last day you were just crushing it yeah
like just feel great every single day
had the race gone on another week or two
maybe you should have done the twenty
one day for the Hat yeah I mean it's
funny because as I as I finished that
race the second time and and in the
first year that I had done it I was
pretty I was blown apart I mean I
couldn't I couldn't walk for a couple
weeks after that race man it had
developed some pretty severe kilise
tendonitis that had hip dysplasia I was
just blown apart going into that race
and seven days and even though I had
been training you know before that it's
not nobody's walking into that thing
unless you've put in a lot of time on
the bike and but physically I was blown
apart in the second year by the time the
last date comes around I actually finish
with the leaders like I'm in like the
the group the guy wins and and one other
guys a few minutes ahead but then I'm
just right in the chase group on the
last day and it was and I came out of
that going wow if there was a day eight
a day nine or day ten I was I was
starting to make up this a lot of this
time that I lost I certainly would have
never won the race but I think I
probably would have ended up you know
had nothing happened that probably would
have been 10th and had the race
continued for another week who knows
maybe I would have jumped up to like
eighth or something like that and and
knowing what you know now
out having immersed yourself in this
world do you I mean do you think any of
the other guys they were racing against
were work doping I mean as an amateur in
that race yes absolutely yeah absolutely
because they're amateur and because the
system was not well monitored there and
the strange thing about sport is I think
so much of it is just for the personal
glory yeah you know you it's hard to
understand but you know as a amateur
athletes at that level are incredibly
competitive and very serious and
especially anybody who's going over to
Europe to go do a seven-day race through
the French Alps and leave their families
go train hundreds of hours on their bike
I think is a lot the same mentality of
guys who want to be in at all cost
it is weird though like you know it's
not your profession you're not making
you know it's yes it's just I can't
fathom doing that and yet I'm not naive
and I know that there are a lot of
people who are doing that and it wasn't
there one guy who holds all kinds of
Strava right yeah that's also the guy
who had who actually won the Haute Route
and I think he's wanted five years in a
row or something his name's Peter Puli
nice guy
and if you look on Strava I don't know
what the e bikes and stuff what may or
may have not changed but this guy
essentially holds the kom up every
single major climb in the Alps the
Pyrenees the dolomite and if you scratch
into his background he was actually he's
French he was in a couple Tour de
France's got caught for doping and
instead of serving his sentence he
retires and goes become becomes a
cycling ambassador for Thailand and
lives in Thailand and his like sponsored
by Singha beer and by the and by the
government of Thailand to be there
cycling ambassador and this guy has been
killing the the Haute Route that's right
the climbs that are
oh yeah I mean great right yeah this
biscuit this guy this guy's got times up
these climbs to rival Froome and whoever
close to it yeah he's he's a that
caliber and but I mean what I gifted
half lead I think he won again this year
I mean and that's the thing that I think
a lot of people forget in this argument
is I don't know whether or not
Peter Puli was or was not taking
substances even though you know if I
look at his past you could certainly
make an argument that he was or is but
on the other hand
it certainly doesn't negate that this
guy is an extraordinary athlete all the
drugs in the world were still not gonna
make me Peter Puli and having and having
experienced that firsthand having gone
through the protocol like does that does
it change how you look at someone like
Lance Armstrong and the you know the
seven tours I think I think look first
of all I think that that cheating is
wrong if you're going in and subscribing
to a set of rules so these rules are put
in place because it's trying to create a
level playing field at least in the
regards of hey you're not gonna take
something that I'm not going to take
that can give you an edge over me if all
things are considered equal and you know
and that is kind of the the the ongoing
battle of clean sport we're on an
ethical and moral level I very much
support clean sport I think that if
you're going into to race in the Tour de
France I'd like to believe that
everybody is is clean and may the best
man win or the best genetic mutant win
and then the flip side of that is you
have a constant game of science and and
and human evolution and medical
evolution and technology which which is
never going to change there's always
going to be
you know another another substance out
there there's always going to be another
experiment and all you got to do is pick
up any science journal every day and
there's been countless articles written
about the athletes of the future and and
and it's the same kind of you know
reality that we're facing that my iPhone
7 is now obsolete because there's an
iPhone 8 things are gonna get really
weird pretty soon you know we're on the
cusp of all kinds of insane
breakthroughs and this Gestalt of
Technology you know is only speeding up
and so you know when you look through
the lens of you know genetic engineering
and being able to you know select the
expression of certain genes you know
where are we gonna draw the line in
terms of what's kosher and what's not
and what does it mean to be on an even
playing field well this this
conversation is going to continue it's
it's never going to stop is so long as
there's hundreds of billions of dollars
at stake and in the world of
professional sports and I think that the
conversation is is gonna have to
continually evolve because it's the
reality of it I mean right now if you've
got a couple hundred thousand dollars
and in the embryo stage you can change
the eye color of your kid you can see to
it that that your child is gonna be six
feet instead of five and five eight
because of why no one and change this
the sex of your baby assumption there's
and why not create a child who's going
to naturally produce more EPO
intersystem than the ordinary kid or
whose lungs are gonna be more efficient
at up taking oxygen or what-have-you you
can create this athlete and is that okay
is that not okay and if you read in
medical science journals that technology
is is is either there right now or it's
on the cusp of being there and so you
know we're heading into a whole other
future that is really outside of
kind of I think what the the creators of
the anti-doping system in sport and wada
could have ever predicted because we're
heading into a land of unknowns far
beyond the pharmacology of it we're
going into you know actually going in
and being able to to modify your genetic
makeup and that's gonna present a whole
other set of problems conundrums
whatever you want to call it as as sport
continues to evolve it is weird that you
know understandably there's a role you
cannot take testosterone exogenously
like that would be a violation of this
protocol but if you were to take some
kind of ayurvedic herb that stimulates
your body's ability to naturally produce
that that's okay well right i mean
you're you're dealing in a world of gray
areas which was under the original film
that I set out to make I was gonna
explore these grey areas these ideas of
okay you can have a if you've got
$15,000 you can be sleeping in a
hyperbaric chamber tens essentially
where your body is going to naturally
create more erythropoietin but you can't
inject erythropoietin you know and I can
go on for hours about all these kind of
gray areas but ultimately it's it's I
think just human nature that we want to
be the best at things and if you're
competitive and anything that you do
whether you're a real estate developer
or you know the list goes on and on and
on you're you know your business man
you're a software programmer you're
always trying to figure out how to be
the best at that and along with that in
sports comes you know trying to figure
out how to to have that extra advantage
and it's not always about taking drugs
it's all sorts of
they're variables that come into place
yeah and I think that it extends beyond
like if you presume the testing agencies
are well-intentioned and that this
system is it's just inherently flawed
because it can't keep up and technology
is moving too fast that's one thing but
you also have to kind of take a look at
the interplay between wada and you sada
and the ioc and you know the FBI and the
DOJ like there's this cabal this sort of
like you know relationship that exists
between all of these that you know it's
just not on the on the level right like
in how like I'm always confused between
you sada
and wada and IOC and who has authority
and who's in charge of this and how does
all of this work and how do they
communicate with each other but it just
seems like a gigantic [ __ ] well
that was as I got into this system and
the exploring of this that is what
became not only clear it was just being
beaten over the head by it on a daily
basis of all the conflicts of interests
and all the you know all these
organizations are intertwined and the
finances are intertwined and you know
and it's increasingly complex because
you realize at the end of the day it is
about the business and the athlete the
individual athlete isn't necessarily the
person who's going to be protected it's
really about what is in the best
interest of the Olympic organization and
despite let's say what they're putting
forward as a public message of of
integrity and fair play and clean sport
and following the rules and unity and
all this stuff at the end of the day
it's about business yeah that's about
what city's gonna bid on the Olympics
the billions of dollars that go into it
and they're not looking out for the
individual interest of the a fleet
they're looking out for their business
model and their business model
punishing Russia doesn't work and
business model caching athletes doesn't
work and their business model truly
fighting for for clean sport doesn't
work those are all counterproductive to
to the business model of the actual
Olympics right so the IOC is you know
arguably their mission statement is
promoting you know the these ideals of
the Olympics and fair sport etc but it
is a gigantic business and you know this
gets played out in the film and we're
jumping ahead a little bit but there's
that there's that thing that occurs and
it's not really completely flushed out
in the movie but in the wake of of you
know all of this evidence that you're on
the receiving end up from Gregory and
turning it over to wada and having them
investigate it becomes clear that
there's like a thousand athletes it's
Sochi that were complicit and arguably
positive and thousand athletes on not
just not Sochi but a child's and Russian
half across all sport across all the
sport yeah and and then okay so what is
the what is gonna be the the punishment
for that and their fate you know Russia
is facing not being able to participate
in Rio right was it was all the Rio
games and now the question is the Winter
Games in Pyeongchang right South Korea
but there was a moment where it looks
like Russia's out and then suddenly like
a couple months later Russia's back in
so you know what's going on in the back
channel there that that decision gets
made the way that it gets made well
we're seeing this go on and and Gregory
and wrote an op-ed to the New York Times
we were able through his lawyers that he
was able to submit an op-ed to the New
York Times because nobody's heard from
him since well he's in what sense he's
brought into protective custody in July
of last year and Gregory wrote the op-ed
because essentially all the the work
that he did to bring this evidence
forward and this evidence was all proven
beyond a reasonable doubt this was
forensic ly proven by Richard McClaren
is essentially being disputed by the
Olympic Committee itself which just
wants to sweep this under the carpet
whadda the world anti-doping agency is
literally questioning the veracity of
the findings of the man that they put in
charge to lead the investigation who
works with Interpol who works with all
these outside agencies who proves
everything forensically scientifically
etc etc but they're trying to poke holes
in in his report and you have the
Russian Ministry no matter how much
evidence has been presented still
completely denying not only that any of
this happened denying the existence of a
state-sponsored doping program denying
you know what is thousands of documents
have evidence the Gregory put forward
and and you're seeing that on all sides
of the equation from the world
anti-doping agency to the Olympics and
and of course Russia that there is
really no resolve to take accountability
for this spectacular fraud that happened
that that cheated every single clean
athlete who went into those Olympic
Games over the last 40 years under the
belief that the rules were being upheld
under the belief that they were playing
on a level playing field and you're
seeing that the actual organizations
that are in charge of of enforcing the
rules really are going to do nothing
that is actually in the best interest of
the clean athletes and only protect
their own business interests and so it's
it's been pretty it's very disheartening
disheartening because what it is doing
is its setting
a message it's sending a message to
every athlete who grows up believing in
the Olympic ideal that you know as a kid
I know that I had this or anybody who
was really serious about sport you grow
up and believing in this Olympic dream
that you're gonna somehow go to the
Olympics and you're competing under
peace and harmony and it doesn't matter
whether you're Russian or American or
from India or from China the world is
coming together to compete and it's all
in the spirit of sport and then what
I've come to realize and what the film
shows is what George Orwell clearly said
is that sport is war without the weapons
and these Olympic Games or World Cup
soccer etc are essentially just a place
for a country to go to war with each
other and assert its geopolitical and
and power through sport right and these
athletes are in essence gladiators for
their country and the case of Russia and
this program that went for forty years
in the case of associate limpets Russia
has been using its sport program to
assert itself geopolitically and show
dominance and power so if you can go in
and win the Olympics you're actually
showing that you're strong that you're
powerful and and those Olympic medals
are almost in place of its of its
nuclear warheads or what it can do on a
geopolitical level and and that is what
countries are viewing the Olympic Games
as it's not about a country going in and
competing peacefully and in harmony of
support money it's about it's about
going in and you look at those Beijing
Olympics in China and and Gregory has
told me repeatedly that he got the idea
to swap out the yeren essentially from
the Chinese at the Beijing Olympics now
these are allegations I have no
knowledge of this but according to
Gregory according to what Gregory told
me is
that the in China the way that the
system was set up is that the athletes
who were reporting for the drug test and
the Chinese athletes would go and report
to essentially Chinese agents and these
agents would give these athletes clean
urine so when they went in to be tested
and they you know and there's an
inspector there watching them
essentially pee that that these athletes
had been given clean urine and that's
why none of the Chinese athletes tested
positive and if you look at the Beijing
Olympics China swept the Beijing
Olympics they won more medals than any
other country but you again you look at
the geopolitics of that and what was on
the line for China
it was China's coming-out party to the
world it's 2008 and China is showing
that not only can they pull off an
Olympics and those Olympic Games were
incredible what they did with the
opening ceremonies in closing sir we've
never seen anything like that in
Olympics history not only can they pull
off the Olympics not only are they a
global superpower but they can win and
I've taken women's sport and they can
win an Olympics what does this say about
business what does this say about war
what does this say about military
strength etc etc and you look at that
and then you draw the analogy to Sochi
or all the other games you know of
course the you know the the the 1936
games in Berlin was one of the the
pivotal moments in in the rise of the
Third Reich and and and of German
nationalism and pride and Hitler used
those games to consolidate his power and
so we're seeing the the the replicating
man in each one of these games where
country is using these games to
basically assert itself on a
geopolitical level
yeah there's no there's no political
will for the truth to come out because
the stakes are too high and the
ramifications of that would be too
disruptive but when you see a situation
like you've presented in the film where
the evidence is so overpowering and
clear-cut and you have to butt up
against a lack of that will
you can't help but walk away from that
feeling a little bit hopeless about what
the future may hold because these
organizations that we've specifically
vested with the authority and the
responsibility of policing this if
they're not even if they're showing
disinterest or they're not going to
actually you know act on it in the way
that you know seems to be the morally
appropriate response then we're lost and
we're only talking about the Olympics
we're not even talking about tennis or
the NBA or the NFL and you know the
implications of you know unfair play on
the professional level across the board
well like well I think that to me the
bigger takeaway is sport is sport and
sport is always going to be a game in
the sense that it is sport I mean as so
long as you're paying NBA players 40
million dollars a year to shoot a basket
with the back you know and and and so
long as you're playing you know NFL
athletes whatever twenty-five thirty
million dollars a year to play football
there is always going to be the the
pressures to win but but to me that the
the bigger issue that we have to look at
and what I want people to take away from
this film is looking at are we as a
country the United States or other
countries willing to tolerate a foreign
powers meddling in our process in our
democracy in our in our political
affairs and what you see in icarus in
this film beyond a reasonable doubt is a
country meddling into the global affairs
of a the Olympics and sport to cheat and
to collude and to and to create a fraud
and B the analogy can clearly be drawn
into our current US political climate
and the and the meddling into our
election of
okay if a country like Russia was
willing to do this to win medals what
else are they willing to do how far they
willing to go and what we're seeing is
no matter how much evidence is put
forward which we see in the film where
not only is this evidence been put
forward it's all been proven and yet you
still have the leaders of the Olympics
and and and and Putin and Russia and
water literally standing in the face of
this evidence trying to deny that this
actually happened and we're seeing the
same thing happen and are in the current
u.s. political situation where no matter
how much evidence is being put forward
about about election tampering of
meddling we're still getting naysayers
we're still getting people going this
didn't happen and I think we have to as
a country and a world go wait what are
we willing to tolerate meaning if we're
willing to tolerate this in sport well I
guess we're willing to tolerate this in
terms of our own election in terms of
Rome political process we're willing to
allow a foreign power to come in and
meddle in our affairs and have that
meddling go unpunished and that to me is
kind of a the take away a vicar estat is
incredibly upsetting where all of this
evidence is presented and you still have
the President of Russia going not only
did this not happen I don't even
remember the guy's name who who brought
all this evidence forward and not only
do we know that this is not true we just
know it's an outright lie and these are
the the the takeaways for me from from
the film that that are frightening and
he's and they're still permitted to send
athletes in the Olympics that's right
you know what I mean you framed the the
film kind of using you know George
Orwell in 1984 to kind of create an
architecture around the themes but
permeating you know beneath that in
every frame of this movie
is the question of the the validity of
truth in our culture right and that's
something that's being called into
question and in a very present and
dangerous way at the moment like how
valuable is truth you present truth and
what is you know what it what are the
consequences of telling the truth and
and what is our cultural response to
being told that the truth and what is
our responsibility to do with that truth
well that's that's exactly right and
what and what we see in the film is that
it appears that the consequences for
truth are are high and in the case of
Gregory which is deeply concerning to me
on a personal level and on a bigger
level is he wrote that op-ed to the New
York Times a week ago which I encourage
anyone listening to this podcast to to
read his New York Times op-ed stating
about essentially the the the crisis of
truth and what is and and despite all
the evidence that he's put forward his
concerns and and two days ago Russia
issues a warrant for his arrest on top
of seizing his assets in Russia a top on
of his criminal charges awaiting him in
Russia taking the home of his daughter
taking the passports of his family
taking their now in a battle to take his
wife's apartment and you're sitting
there going wait so the man who came
forward with the truth is this is going
to be the man who is punished for
telling the truth and that's really
really frightening and that's something
that we have to be worried about as as a
planet because of the consequences of
telling the truth are are your
imprisonment your punishment for trying
to
bring forward a story that needed to be
told to the world that's that's that's
concerning I mean on a really really big
level and and you know and I'm and I'm
really worried for him in that regard
that that instead of being exalted for
telling the truth he is being demonized
for telling the truth and we're in and
we're in a news cycle and a world cycle
that is that is allowing this literally
two weeks ago Russia puts out a new
statement through the RT and through
Sputnik news that wada was willing to
drop all the charges against Russia that
rich and McLaren had found errors in his
report and that and that and that they
believed that Russia should be
reinstated to competition and it allowed
into the Winter Games none of this was
true this was fake news a hundred
percent fake news yet it was picked up
by all the global newspapers as as truth
and so here was here is this
crystal-clear example and and we're of
course seeing in regards to our own
election and everything we're reading
these stories out of Twitter and
Facebook etc etc but here firsthand I'm
watching this story I'm reading this
report and going not only is this true
not true this is a fake news story and
it was picked up by newspapers all over
the world and the next day Richard
McClaren is out there making statements
going this is not true and yet the news
has moved on exact right and we should
point out for the listener and just so
we're clear like Gregory comes the
United States to work with you and he
bring in and in the wake of this
McClaren report that comes out that's
basically indicating that there is all
of this fraud going on in Russia he
brings with him all of these hard drives
that you guys
begin to you know you you hide them in
safety in safe places and you start to
get into all of this stuff and realize
like this is all the evidence of what is
happening and through a kind of a
drawn-out process make this decision to
turn these materials over to the New
York Times
hence turning Gregory into sort of a
Snowden like figure but then you know
he's he's in danger his life is at risk
and ultimately he ends up in protective
custody which is where he remains today
do you and and and this New York Times
article comes out there's a lot of news
around this and a lot of discussion and
obviously blowback on Russia that
they've survived but you know it didn't
look good for Putin for all this to come
out do you when you look at the last
election cycle how do you think about
the relationship between that scandal
that you were you know at Ground Zero
for and being involved in that New York
Times story do you see a relationship
between that and Putin deciding to roll
up his sleeves and start meddling in our
election process in our democratic
process like do you think there's any
logic and saying well oh yeah you're
gonna screw with me this way like let me
show you how I you know what I can do
well
you know I I don't know because I'm not
a I'm not privy to the knowledge that
the FBI or CIA or NSA has in January of
this year they they released their
Declassified report into the election
meddling and they listed seven reasons
as to why they believed our election was
hacked and reason three they listed was
for what Putin or Russia viewed as the
u.s. involvement in the doping scandal
and the Panama papers and and what was
meant by that is that because raw
chenkov essentially had come to the
United States on a visa because the
story was brought to the New York Times
which is an American paper and because
the Department of Justice and FBI
launched an investigation and because
or a chenkov was put into protective
custody by American authorities that
that Russia believed that the United
States apparently was trying to
embarrass Russia and was behind
essentially the breaking of the scandal
which is not true that's not what
happened at all but clearly I think you
can think within that mentality about
government why you would perhaps believe
that the United States might have been
involved in that but Gregory was
certainly acting not only on his own
volition but on his own ethical and
moral compass of just having a desire
insatiable desire that he had to bring
this story public that that it was so
important that this story was known and
that and that the world knew that this
had happened but you know I think I
think what we're seeing now which is in
the fallout of this election meddling is
that the film shows without a question
of a doubt the extent to which Russia's
willing to go a to conceal truth and to
deny accountability and be perpetrating
a fraud to essentially advance their own
geopolitical interests and in this case
they were using sport to do that and in
the case of as it appears to be in our
election process they were using you
know fake news and ads and all sorts of
other methods of infiltrating our
society to try to help assist you know
the current administration to be elected
at least as what is being alleged
and and if I'm looking at what I know at
least in regards to the Icarus story in
the story behind the Olympic doping
scandal and Russia's involvement of this
in the last 40 years it's not that far
of a leap to to believe that that this
is happening
it's unbelievable there are so many
strings to pull III just I can't imagine
the job of trying to edit this movie
because there's so many other stories
that you could pursue and I would
imagine there were a lot of threads that
you pulled that ended up on the cutting
room floor so you know if if length and
time was not a limitation on this
project on this movie where would this
exploration lead you next I mean does it
lead you to you sada to the IOC does it
lead you directly to Putin like where do
you go you know it's funny you know is
we were going through editing my editors
there was a time where I had four
assistant editors and three main editors
I mean we had seven editors because it
was so much footage so much and then I
had people just pulling archival footage
and and it was just this this team and
all of us and and my producing partner
Dan Cogan and and also my investors that
became producers on the project we were
all so emotionally invested and
personally invested in the story that
and there were so many areas of central
II fraud and wrongdoing you know you you
could go down the rabbit hole and and
and I remember through this process I
went how we could weakens Pingris four
hundred fights
and and every single thing is is
compelling in and of itself and I
remember that that that we went through
everything from in the beginning of the
film where I was going to as part of my
journey show how the National Football
League how the how the testing system
and the NFL is a joke and how it's
basically been put to
by the Players Union and the owners
union to essentially create a system
that appears that there's Anti Doping in
the NFL well essentially all these guys
are just allowed to do whatever they
want to do and no one cares cares and I
was and I was gonna explore how
basketball essentially doesn't even have
any anti-doping system and anytime any
basketball is questioned about that they
they go to you know the the layers of
levels of abuse within the NBA and all
these other you know social problems so
I was going to initially explore and how
tennis and I could go on and on and on
about all these different sports and
federations how their systems are highly
an adequate so there was that story that
I realized essentially had to drop away
because we didn't have time and the film
to tell that story there was the story
of wada
where i could have went deep into the
rabbit hole of that where where wada had
been receiving information for four
years from the initial russian
whistleblowers Battaglia and Yuliya
Stepanova
who had been going to water telling him
hey there's a state-sponsored program in
Russia and wada doesn't do anything
about it
for years and even though when you're
there you're like here it all is and
they're kind of like yeah okay like what
are we supposed to do is that like art
you know and and and and so on so we had
you know there could have been a whole
film on on on that and and there were
other Russians coming to water over the
years and years and and even the fact
that that Don Catlin refers me to
Gregory were chenkov because Catlin
knows that that the Russians are up to
no good and do you think that he knew
like in the back of his mind that like
if he got you with Gregory that he would
start to get a glimpse of what was
actually how he had no idea I don't
think anybody could have imagined what
they had done at Sochi the the the
bottle swapping operation I think just
was mind-boggling that it went to that
level but he certainly knew that
Russia had not been playing by the rules
as well as I think pretty much any
scientists in the world of anti-doping
in the lab system there was they they
they knew in theory that you know things
were not being upheld because of how the
system was structured so you know I
could have went on a multi-part series
on on wada and how the IOC Co funds wada
and all the conflicts of interests and
how the president of wada sits on the
board and is the vice president of the
IOC and I mean I could go on for a li
you know I could I could have done a
huge expose on the Olympics and and all
the politics within there and and and
the stories that Gregory has told me and
that he even has knowledge and
information about of I mean all these
various Olympic cover-ups and all these
you know the problems within that
organization I could have I could have
went down that rabbit hole but
ultimately the the story that needed to
be told and the film for me was not
going to be a multi-part series it
wasn't going to be an explorative
exploratory expose on all the in
justices and the in the sporting world
but to me that the biggest story of the
film and what had to be told was
Gregory's journey and this journey that
ultimately leads him to being a
whistleblower ultimately leads to
exposing the single biggest scandal in
sport history the single biggest scandal
in Olympic history and ultimately the
takeaway of that which in the film we
craft in the world of Orwell which is
the world of doublethink which is
essentially doing one thing and saying
the exact opposite and that was
essentially Gregory's life and
everything that's been going on within
the larger sporting world of saying the
ear upholding integrity and values in
clean sport while do
doing nothing about actually doing that
or presenting you know a test that is
the anti-doping test well at the same
time you've developed the anti-venom to
the test and and and these were the the
larger takeaways of the film that that
became important in that story that we
needed to tell and so we had to edit
orally lose anything in that process
that wasn't going on that journey of
Gregory's story and the exposing of this
scandal to the world and so there was so
much that that is on the cutting room
floor that I guess could make myriads of
series of course well I mean Gregory is
the ultimate cipher because he's so
likable and you can connect with him and
and people the audience I think connect
with your relationship with him you know
it could have very easily turned out
that this guy was unlikable or just
completely unsympathetic but the fact
that he is so jocular like you you just
want you want him to be okay despite the
flaws and the actions that he's taken
and so it allows the audience member to
open up to this story and receive it in
a way that I think somebody other than
Gregory would not have been able to
deliver yeah I mean he's I mean that's
the you know I guess the conundrum of
Gregory on on one hand you love him and
he is the most lovable likeable
character I think you're likely you know
going to encounter in a documentary in
quite some time he's just has this way
about him that you love and at the same
time he has spent his life being
involved in a very complicated scandal
and and concealing what was a
institutional conspiracy to cheat sport
and the Olympics
and his Redemption is breaking free of
that system that he was a part of and
bringing that story to the world it
doesn't change what happened it doesn't
change the history it doesn't change
that he was a part of these I guess you
know what you would call sporting crimes
or fraud but his coming forward sets the
record straight and without him and
without his willingness to to bring this
story forward the world would never know
this I mean this this story lived and
died ultimately in Gregory's hands he
was the only person on planet Earth to
this day that had this evidence because
even everybody else working in the
laboratory they had pieces and parts
they didn't have the actual evidence and
Gregory did and the other two guys in
Russia who both died of heart attacks
even they were not involved in a
laboratory level they knew of the system
going on they knew of how the system was
operating but they weren't in the lab
level the scientific level where this
story could be proven so so that so this
story lived and died with Gregory and
ultimately Gregory made a spectacular
sacrifice not only to leave his family
but to have an unknown fate going
forward and into the world and and the
risks that he took to bring this story
forward are pretty pretty remarkable and
so I felt a a huge burden on one hand
and an honor on the other to be able to
to tell this story that and and bring
this story forward which is there was
never a question in my mind or my team's
mind as to whether or not we wanted to
to help him
tell this story were you ever in a
situation in which a conflict of
interest presented itself in other words
what's in the best interest of the firm
or the firm the the film versus what's
in Gregory's best interest in terms of
kind of navigating these decisions about
the New York Times and the investigation
and all of that you know it because
gregor and i truly have a friendship had
a friendship there was a period of time
for about seven months for he comes a
los angeles between us breaking the
story to the new york times where it was
we were filming when we were making a
movie still but it was beside the point
of the gravitas of what we were sitting
on and understanding that we were
sitting on this evidence and this
knowledge and this wealth of information
that was in my opinion and Gregory's
opinion and my producers opinion
incredibly important that that that the
world needed to have this information
and so it became how do we navigate this
in the best interest of Gregory and all
the clean athletes who needed this
information and then the best interests
of of seeing to it that this story came
forward and that the truth was told
rather than in the interests of the film
or or perhaps what could have been you
know financial interests and and we had
moments where we were going okay do we
just bring this information forward in
the film and we realized that that if we
did not that it would maybe serving the
film's purpose and the explosive nature
of these allegations in the in the film
but it wasn't going to be serving
Gregory's purpose it wasn't going to be
serving the greater good's purpose
because what would happen is
bring that story forward and then
everybody would attack it and then the
film would be on the defensive is
something explosive and who knows
whether or not that story could have
been proven so you know myself and my
producing team and Gregory we said no
that's not the way to do it and the way
that the best way to do this and we
didn't have faith in the United States
government as as that investigation
heated up because who knows what the US
government was going to do with this
information and they didn't have what
were they gonna do it that they don't
have international jurisdiction to be
able to go retest urine samples that are
being held by the Olympics so so we made
a collective series of decisions but
each one of those decisions that we made
at least in my opinion
we were looking at what is in the best
interests of Gregory of how to protect
him how to see to it that that this
stories is is truthfully told and what
is in the best interest of the sporting
world to have this information and to
have this knowledge and how can we see
to it that that this story is not that
this story is not covered up that it can
be proven and so by going to the New
York Times we were essentially allowing
this story that it that was a blessing
and a burden to to leave our control and
to allow the authorities who could truly
investigate this and prove this to take
over and we knew that if we went to the
New York Times that it was going to be
impartial in its judgment and that it
wasn't going to be a story for the
tabloids it was it was now a news story
now if we could and if we can navigate a
news story then there was there was a
chance that that everything that Gregory
had brought forward which myself and my
producing team really had no questioned
as to the veracity of it whether or not
it was true it was how do we bring it
forward
had to be terrifying as soon as that was
published though but Gregory seemed
pretty chill about the whole thing at
least on Phil II he was chill and the
interesting thing about Gregory is he's
said to me many times as as I personally
was in the middle of this crisis and
going oh my god what have you gotten
yourself into Brian what have you got
your partners and your investors into
and your you know like this is what he's
doing you're in over your head and I
certainly felt that many times and
Gregory always felt that and I think he
does to this day that every day
he's alive is an extra day that he was
not going to be alive should he have
stayed in in Russia that's one
perspective and he viewed himself that
he was essentially dead man walking and
so every day that that that that he's
alive and I think he has this belief
right now today that every day that he's
alive is another day that he wouldn't
have been alive had had he not made the
the choices he made and so I think he's
looking at it from a different
perspective that he in many ways got to
live on borrowed time where I think
myself and my creative and producing
team had a consistent you know feeling
of overwhelming gravity to what was
being presented to us because we were
not the ones who were personally
involved years of this conspiracy we
have to land this plane but before we do
is he okay like what's the status of
the investigation what is the future
prognosis for what's going to happen to
him well the Department of Justice and
FBI still have their ongoing
investigation into the into the doping
scandal into the you know his his
evidence and I think they haven't
decided yet if we're going to bring a
case and and if they do who they would
bring that case against he is okay right
now we launched fair sport dot-org one
of my producers in the film launched an
organization called fair sport org a
nonprofit was essentially launched to
help protect whistleblowers in sport and
also to help continue to protect to
navigate Gregory's well-being and and
this organization is trying to a see to
it that there are is some justice that
is done based on you know the evidence
that is brought forward and also help
protect athletes rights that were that
had medals taken from them try to help
athletes you know stand up to
authorities that are not you know
operating in their best interests but
also really help other whistleblowers
and support people like Gregory who
might have a story to tell and to that
extent we established a GoFundMe for
Gregory that if any of your listeners or
on the site can go and find um on
GoFundMe and the hope is is that we can
raise enough money to continue to assist
Gregory in his well-being because the
future right now for him is unknown and
it's and it's deeply concerned on a lot
of levels and and we're hoping that that
he's okay now and he's gonna be okay in
a year from now he's gonna be
okay and another year from now and the
question of how and when when he'll ever
be reunited with his family if ever is
lingering and as you see from Russia's
response and that New York Times op-ed
and and what you see in the film is that
this story is far from over
it was we had a moment where we were
capturing essentially history as it was
unfolding and it's still unfolding and
we're still seeing the unfolding of this
on our daily news cycle in regards to
Russia and in regards to what is going
on and in our current political climate
and so this story is not is not done
this is not this is not past history
it's it was unfolding history current
history and now future history as to
what will happen for sport in the
Olympic and the Olympic movement what it
will happen to Gregory and his life and
his livelihood and his family and his
well-being and what our country and
other countries of the world are going
to essentially tolerate or not tolerate
from our leaders and whether or not
we're going to allow this continual
cycle of fake news and and Orwellian
doublethink 1984 thinking to to
perpetuate our society and to continue
and and whether or not we're going to
take action against that
on that note you you went to Congress
right and spoke so what was that like
and and how does that have you feeling
in the wake of that does it make you
optimistic that we can have that
discussion and create change or no well
I I spent a few days in Washington about
a month and a half ago meeting with the
Chiefs of Staff of a number of
bipartisan Senate offices and all of
them were very interested in looking at
the film and perhaps doing a hearings
perhaps doing screenings I don't know
what's going to happen with that or not
that's
that is hopefully in the works but that
experience was surreal on the one at
least take away that I felt and speaking
to whether it was a Republican office or
a Democrat office that I saw a mutual
interest from from an American
perspective to to try to see to it that
not only does what the evidence that is
presented in the film as far as this
spectacular conspiracy to to cheat sport
not continue but also that that the
United States interest to see to it that
there is some sort of change in the
system that that what potentially
happened in the last election doesn't
repeat itself again and there certainly
seemed to be a very mutual shared
interest in that and I guess history
will determine whether or not something
is ultimately done and not done but it's
it's a pretty a pretty scary story when
you really start thinking about the
bigger implications behind it it's
strange times that we live in and it
truly is Orwellian in many ways and
truth is under attack and I think it's
never been more important for us to be
discerning about the news that we
consume and and our responsibility to to
to speak the truth and to speak truth to
power and that's certainly what you've
done in this film and it's quite amazing
so for people that have not seen it I
strongly suggest you check it out even
though this was basically a two-hour
spoiler it doesn't matter it's really
quite something man so thank you for
making the movie and I'm wishing Gregory
well and I'm wishing your journey well
and I hope that you make more movies in
this vein yeah I appreciate it I hope I
hope the film occur
is currently streaming on on Netflix so
you can find it and and I'm looking at
other projects right now in the
documentary space to take these this
knowledge that that I've had and this
experience and and expand upon that into
into other subjects and in the
documentary space because I what is
really cool I think about documentary
and amazing is that as a filmmaker you
can set out on on a journey and you
ultimately don't know where it's going
to lead to and creatively you have the
power to craft anything you want because
it's an unscripted format which which
opens up the world of possibilities but
you also don't know what you're going
into and in case of this I I couldn't
have imagined as I set out on this
journey that I would end up where it led
to and that I would end up with Gregory
and my team exposing this this gigantic
conspiracy and scandal but that I would
also end up so much wiser an
understanding of the world that we're
living in and that is something very
cool about documentary that it can take
you on a journey that is not only
unexpected but that can actually have
impact and change in the world so I'm
hoping to continue to make projects that
that do that yeah I would imagine you
feel some level of responsibility to do
so to continue this conversation in a
variety of ways you know extending the
themes that you've introduced in this
movie that's what I'm looking to do and
hopefully the more eyes on this film
will allow me to continue on that
journey cool thanks man
thanks for talking to me if people want
to connect with Brian you're a prime
Fogel on twitter right at our other
places where people can reach you in the
main way at
Brian Fogle on Twitter Brian with the
why BR why a n fo GTL on Twitter I have
a website Brian Fogle comm and the movie
is Icarus on Netflix and are you doing
any screenings coming up
are you traveling around with a movie or
what's going on the film launched August
4th Netflix is in the process of
scheduling they've scheduled a lot of
screenings for for various groups and
critics and things like that and I think
they are planning some you know
screenings coming up in in the near
future but certainly it being on the
platform it's globally available and I
just want you're doing like q and A's or
any kind of live events thing because
I'm sure people would love to see you
get up and have a conversation with
somebody relevant to the movie yeah that
that's that's that's in the works and
they're there they're trying to to get
those planned right now is we kind of
had into the next several months so I
don't have specifics on that but I do
know that there there will be some
screenings and talk backs and q and A's
are there gonna be any like you know
like akin to the DVD extras like if
there's so many so much footage you're
sitting on I would imagine there's all
kinds of other stories that you could
tell that are relevant
you could probably spend the next couple
of years working on that oh yeah but I
would love to see some of the stuff that
you had to cut for time oh there was so
much I mean because in the in the like I
interviewed guys like Alex Gibney the
documentary filmmaker who did the
Armstrong lie who's just brilliant and
and the interview that I shot with him
was so compelling I interviewed Victor
Conti I interviewed Tyler Hamilton and
and Timmy Duggan and I interviewed all
these other scientists and Europe and
and sporting officials and
so yeah I mean the the amount of footage
that I compiled is pretty pretty vast
and and 97 percent of it didn't make it
into the film so yeah that could I guess
be an addendum that could be the ongoing
docu-series I'm gonna sit here and hold
my breath until yeah all right man
you're talking you thank you thanks rich
piece
you